so i'm going to multiply 16 times 27 and
i'm going to do it using something
called an area model and the whole point
of an area model is to really understand
what's going on in the multiplication
process
so 16 you can represent literally as ten
plus six this one is in the tenths place
it represents one ten so we can
represent that as ten
ten
plus
ten
plus six let me do the six in that same
green color
10
plus
6 and let me mark off 10 and 6 years so
this is 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. so this part in blue
that's the 10.
so i'm representing i've gone 10 slashes
or i'm representing 10 boxes right over
there and then the six actually i want
to do in that green color i still did in
that the six let's mark off six boxes
one
two three
four
five six so 16 is this whole length the
blue part is the 10 the green part is
the six the 10 comes from the one in the
tens place it's literally one ten and
this is literally six ones now let's
think about 27
27 well we already know that the two in
the tens place is representing 20 so
let's count off 20. so it's 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8
9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20. so up until that point right over
here this line right over here has a
length of 20. this has a length of 20.
but we're not just talking about 20
we're talking about 27 so it's 20 plus
7. so 20 plus seven so let's count off
seven here
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
now if we look at the total number so if
we have 16 times 27 the product 16 times
27 would give you the area of a 16 by 27
rectangle so let me draw that so it's 16
this is a width of 16. let's bring let's
bring a little line down
right over here
and then the height
of my rectangle the way i've drawn it is
27
is 27. so let me
27 so this is 1 2 3 four five six seven
so the area of this rectangle is going
to be 16 times 27 the area of this
entire rectangle now we could do is
break it up by parts because it'll be
easier to compute and we can see what
those what those it what part of the
area those different products represent
so for example we can think about what
10 so let me draw although let me make
this let me separate out the sections
so let me draw so this section
is 10 wide and then let me draw the
section like this
let me draw a section
like this so we can figure out the areas
of each of these sections and then the
area of the entire rectangle which is
going to be this product is going to be
the area of all of these rectangles
combined so we could first think about
it well let's think about what 20 times
10 is well 20 times 10 is a fairly
straightforward thing it's going to be
it's going to be 200 you can already
think of it as 2 times 1 and you have 2
0's there or you probably know in your
head 20 times 10 is just going to be
you're going to add a 0 here so it's
going to be 200. so 20 times 10 is 200
and let me highlight that in so
you have that's not the color i wanted
to use
let me use this blue right here
so
that's the blue from the 10.
let me put some orange in there from the
20 to make it clear that this is the
product of both of those numbers so 20
times 10
20 times 10 is 200
now what's 20 times 6
well 2 times 6 is 12
plus you have this 0 here so this right
over here is going to be 120 and it has
the orange in it it has the orange in it
so this is the 20
and then let me put some green in for
the 6 20
times
20
times the 6.
now what's the area of this section
right over here well it's 7 high and it
is 10 wide so it's going to be 7 times
10
or 70.
and i'll have an area of 70 square units
so
let me do it in this purple
do purple and i'll throw some blue in
there too
it's kind of a fun art project i'll
throw some blue in there too and then
finally what's the area of this little
section right over here it's 7 high and
it's 6 wide so it's going to be 7 times
6 or 42 square units of area
42 square units of area and let me color
it in so i got some magenta in there
and then i got some green in there so i
have some green in there right over
there so what's the area of this entire
thing going to be well it's going to be
the 200
it's going to be the 200
plus the 120
plus let me do it this way it's going to
be 200 plus 120
plus 70
plus 42.
and when you add that up you get let's
see in the ones place you get a 2 then
you get 2 tens plus seven tens is nine
tens plus four tens is 13 tens which is
the same thing as three tens
and one
hundred and then this is a four did i
add that up right let's see this will be
eleven yep that looks right so this is
432
so this is going to be equal to
this is equal to
432 and you might be saying hey sal why
did we go through all of this business
you know i've seen before that if i take
16 i could take 16
times 27 like this you probably learned
this type of a this type of a process 16
times 27 and you say okay let's start
with the 7 in the ones place and you do
7 times 6 is 42 is 42. you write the 2
down and you carry the 4 you're really
just putting the 4 in the tenths place
because it's a 40. but there right when
you right when you did that 7 times the
6 we essentially calculated this right
over there and then when you multiply
the 7 times the 1 you're really
multiplying 7 times 10 and then you're
adding the 4 from the 42. so when you do
the 7 times this 1 this is you're
actually calculating this area and then
when you carry when you add this carried
four and put it right down here you're
essentially taking the sum of both of
these things because you're multiplying
7 times the 16 to get this area 7 times
the 16 to get this area so let's just do
it 7 times 1 is 7
plus four is eleven
eleven so a hundred twelve what you just
figured out right over here is this area
right over here so seven times one or
the seventy or seven times the ten or
the seventy plus 7 times 6 the 42.
now when you go into the tens place
you've probably always said oh well you
know i just throw a i just throw a 0
down there but why do you throw a 0 down
there because this 2 is representing 10.
so if you multiply a 2 times a 6 and you
wrote put a you know 12 and we put a 2
down and carried the 1 that wouldn't be
right this is a 20. so that's why you
put the 0 there so let's scratch this
out so we don't get confused 2 times 6
is 12. so we're used to writing the 2
down here
2 down here and carrying the 1 but
notice we're really thinking about 20
times 60 is 120. just doing that we just
calculated that right over there and
then we do 20 times 10
is 200 but then we had that one from the
120 so this is going to be 300. so this
is going to be 300. so what we just did
when we multiply the 2 times the 16 we
just calculated this
total area we did the 2 times 20 times
the 6 to get that and then we had the 20
times the 10 to get that when we did the
20 times the 6 we carried this 1 into
the hundreds place and so we added it
all together and got 320 and then this
step right over here you're literally
just finding the you're the combined
area the area of this plus the area of
that the area of this plus the area of
that so that's going to get us to
we deserve a drum roll now 2 plus 0 is 2
1 plus 2 is 3 1 plus 3 is 4.